mag je werkgever één dag van tevoren
je rooster veranderen
dus dat je eerst vier uur moest beginnen
en nu om drie uur
als het in jouw nadeel is
namelijk dat je dus meer moet werken
dan mag jouw werkgever dat niet zomaar aanpassen
dan moet hij daar naar vragen ja
om toestemming vragen en jij mag dan nee zeggen
in het geval dat het dus één dag van tevoren is
op het moment
dat jouw dienst wordt veranderd naar kortere uren
dan hoeft een werkgever
hier geen toestemming voor te vragen
maar is wel verplicht om de volledige uh werk
tijd van de dienst uitbetalen
dus had je eerst een dienst van zes uur
en dat wordt vijf uur
een dag van tevoren of op dezelfde dag
dat is prima maar moet hij wel die zes uur uitbetalen
dit geldt overigens voor alles
wat binnen vier dagen wordt gewijzigd
let op want een cao kan hiervan afwijken naar één dag
dit heeft alles te maken met de wet wab
wil je daar nou meer over weten
download dan mijn ebook